Ok tenemos por aquí dos
polinomios que se están sumando y nos están pidiendo que los simplifiquemos.
¿Ok? Ahora para empezar aquí tenemos estos
paréntesis y un más en medio, y pues de hecho nos podemos deshacer de esos paréntesis,
por que en realidad no está afectando para nada al segundo paréntesis ¿Ok? Y una vez que nos deshagamos de esos
paréntesis, lo que vamos a hacer es agrupar todos los términos que tengan el mismo grado, por ejemplo
vamos a agrupar todos los términos que tengan "x" cuadrada y le vamos a sumar
la agrupación de todos los términos que tengan "x", y luego todos los términos que no tengan "x" ¿Ok? Entonces
pues empecemos por deshacernos de esos dos paréntesis.
Vamos a volver a escribirlo todo, aquí esto es
5x cuadrada más 8x -3
y ahora más
este más de aquí
2x cuadrada y bueno de hecho, si este en lugar de ser un más hubiera sido un -
entonces, hubiera tenido que distribuir el menos en cada uno de estos términos ¿Ok? Hubiera quedado -2x cuadrada
y luego menos -7x
y finalmente -13x pero pues es un más entonces nos queda 2x cuadrada -7x
más 13x y ahora pues tenemos que escoger
alguna de las potencias de "x", podemos escoger "x" al cuadrado
y pues nos vamos a buscar todos los términos de éste bonche de
términos que tengan "x" al cuadrado ¿Ok? Éste tiene "x" al cuadrado, éste no, éste no,
esté también tiene "x" al cuadrado, y éste tampoco, y tampoco entonces, los agrupamos. Tenemos
5 de esta cosa que es "x" al cuadrado más 2 de esa misma cosa pues entonces tenemos que tener
7 de esa cosa que es "x" al cuadrado
bueno entonces, vamos ahora con la siguiente potencia de "x"
tenemos por aquí 8x -3 no tiene "x"
estos 2 pues tienen "x" cuadrada en lugar de "x" entonces obviamente no los vamos a volver a sumar y por aquí tenemos
-7x y 13x aunque entonces aquí le tenemos que suma
8x -7x más 13x que finalmente es 8
- 7 y nos queda 1 y luego más 13 entonces, nos queda
14x  y finalmente
buscamos los términos que no tienen ninguna "x" y pues el único término con esa forma es este de aquí,
así es que nos queda -3.
Podemos pensar en este -3 como en "x" a la 0 por que cualquier cosa al 0 es 1,
entonces nos quedaría -3 por "x" a la 0 que es igual a -3 por 1 que es -3
pero pues es simplemente el término constante ¿Ok? El chiste es que ya terminamos de simplificar esta expresión
y listo.